speaking out against social injustice
Spike Lee I know you were at a vigil in
New York yesterday so where's your heart
at this moment I'm taking it day by day
just this country United States
America's in turmoil right now my heart
isn't a good place though something I've
seen on television I wanted to see my
own eyes and what has given me strength
is my fellow white brothers and sisters
out there
strong and what's really even give me
even more height is like the number of
young white brothers and sisters I'm 63
you know we had to repent the movement
the anti-war movement the women's
movement and all that stuff we haven't
seen this since the 60s so that gives me
hope
Spike's known for speaking up for what
he believes back in 1992 he told et this
about the not guilty verdict for the
police officers in the Rodney King case
black people for the most part African
Americans the most part I feel is still
second-class citizens in this country I
mean any killed they beat his ass but
ain't killed me now we're getting snuff
films and when it comes to work Spike
always has a message in his movies his
latest the five Bloods is about former
soldiers who returned to Vietnam to
search for the remains of their fallen
squad leader played by Chadwick Boseman
we've been dying for this country from
the very get you have a film out that
speaks to the times it's so relevant war
is helm who when these cats came back
Vietnam it was no medical term you know
whole stress and you know on that they
just said they were shell-shocked
one theme of the movie the traumas of
our past still affect who we are today
hosts slavery syndrome we are still
dealing with trauma from slavery we are
still dealing with that as a people
[Music]